hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation
part of agilent's virtual energy and
chemical summit
i am abby pell of lab roots and i will
be your moderator
for today's event now let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions
as you would like during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click
click on the ask a question box located
on the far
left of your screen i now present
today's speaker
shannon coleman demystifying valve
chroma chromatography for a complete
biography on today's speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
shannon coleman you may now begin your
presentation
and thank you all for coming uh welcome
i'm happy you could make it to my event
today my name is shannon coleman i'm an
application scientist here at agilent
technologies
and i'm here today to talk to you about
uh gc rotary valve
modes of operation and application so
you can see here i have a 7890 bgc
hold on a second and uh
up here down here on the on the front
panel you can see a plumbing diagram
when a lot of times when i go into
customers
uh labs i'll see a gc setting on the on
the bench
and it'll have a large valve oven on it
and when i see a valve oven on a gc i
immediately ask the customer so where's
your plumbing diagram let me take a look
at that diagram
because that diagram is going to tell me
a couple of things it's going to tell me
how the gc is configured and and how the
gc is intended to operate
so today in this presentation uh
hopefully
i can give you the groundwork uh to
where you'll understand how to read
these diagrams
you'll understand the basic mechanics of
how valves work
and you'll also have the knowledge to
troubleshoot some of the valve
applications that you might be working
with
and also if you have any new
applications
that you're considering for matrixes
that are complex that
may be more complex than just simple
inlet to detector
then valve gc might be necessary and
hopefully i can give you the tools about
how to start to think about
those applications so let's get started
i'm going to walk back over here to my
computer
and we'll get started with the
presentation
so let's get started just with some
basics of understanding valves you can
see here
we have a plumbing diagram and at first
glance it's quite complicated
um i was talking to one customer one
time and they said you know shannon this
just looks like a big plate of spaghetti
to me
how am i supposed to understand uh
what's going on with all of these lines
crossing and intersecting and that sort
of thing and i realized at that point
that
you know if it's not something you've
been looking at a lot
it can seem quite daunting and uh
intimidating so hopefully today we can
give you some tools to eliminate some of
the trepidation that comes along with
with understanding how to look at
complex valve systems
so how are valves used in chromatography
it's really pretty simple
um there's really three primary
functions of a
gas valve on a gc one would be to select
a specific sample
uh for injection so there's such things
as
multi-position stream select valves or
you could have multiple streams
gas phase streams coming into an
instrument
and you can use a valve to select one of
those streams to deliver to the
instrument for analysis
the second mode of operation
is typically injection of a sample and
this is probably the most common thing
you'll see you'll see a gas sample valve
on the instrument for injecting a gas
phase sample
and then the third primary function
would be just to change the direction of
flow
of the gases in the instrument as they
flow through the instrument from the
injection point to the detectors and
that's really pretty much it
i mean there's not a whole lot more to
it than that now the valves themselves
get a little bit more complica
you know the the designs of how how you
plumb the valve can
can be quite complicated sometimes so
that's what we're going to try to focus
on here but keep in mind that
really the purpose of these valves is
those three things and that's
what you'll run into the common theme
throughout this
this presentation so one of the things i
want to talk to you about is is just
you know start very basic and start
about you know how to read a
what do these valves mean on the diagram
and what how are the drawings laid out
to show you
how the valve is functioning so if you
look at a valve here's a four port
rotary valve
here's a six port rotary valve and
here's a ten port and
we're today we're going to focus mostly
on six port and temp
valves although there are other larger
valves
than these there's 14 port and 16 port
valves
but for simplicity's sake we're going to
focus on these two valves here
you can see on each one of the valves
you we have a dot
on the valve here this four port valve
has four points and these are connection
points
these are points where on the actual
physical valve where we would attach a
tube
to allow gas to flow in or out of the
valve
and then these points are connected by a
line and this line
is designates a flow path as an
enable between these two points
so you need to remember that if there's
a line between two ports that flow is
enabled between those two ports
ports three and four do not have flow
enabled now if we switch the valve
to the on position um ports three and
four would be enabled and port three and
two would not be enabled
so it's important to note that when you
look at one of these
valves on paper how do you know if the
valve is either in the on or the off
position
well you know because it's pretty much
an industry-wide standard
that when drawing valves you draw them
in their de-energized
or they're off position and then
whoever's reading the diagram can then
have
some confidence that as they're looking
at the diagram
that they know that valve is in the off
position
you can see here i have a cad drawing of
an actual rotary valve
and you can tell by looking at this
valve
that there's no way to tell what
position the valve's in
is it on or is it off you don't know
so you can see here there's some ports
16
inch ports on the valve each port has a
number
on the valve stamped on the valve so you
can see here ports one and six this
happens to be a six port valve
and you can see how this directly
correlates with the drawing
so we know if this valve is installed on
the instrument
and we turn that valve off then ports
1 and 6 will have flow
enabled between them so when the valve
is in the off position
we know from the drawing that since the
drawing
valves are drawn in the opposition when
we turn this valve off
ports one and six have flow enabled
between them so that's the only way to
really know
um you know what position that valve's
in or where the flows are in the valve
is through this convention on how we
draw them
and plumb them if you look a little
closer at the valve
body and you start to disassemble it
you can see there's three major parts
to the valve body you can see here we
have a stainless steel valve body we
have our ports with our tubes coming in
and out of it
this happens to be a gas sample valve
you can see the gas sample loop going
around and back into the valve here
you can see the inside of the valve is a
rotor
and there on top of the rotor screws
down a preload assembly that provides
tension on the rotor that prevents
gases from leaking out of the valve as
it's
in use you take the preload assembly off
and you look directly
down on top of the valve you can see the
back end of the rotor
and then if you take the rotor out of
the valve and you look directly down
into the valve body you can see
that there's a key drive slot
down inside of of the valve body
if you look closer at the rotor you can
see that there's a rotor tab
and this tab fits down inside of
this keyed slot which is an indentation
in the bottom of the valve body
and that's how we use the valve driver
or the the valve
actuator to turn this rotor
into one position or another if you look
at the
more closely at the valve rotor you can
see that the rotors
like the valve body made out of
stainless steel
and then there's a rotor groove machined
through this polymer coating on the
valve here
this rotor groove is relates to that
line that's drawn on the valve diagram
so the the connection point between the
two ports
is made by this rotor groove that allows
gas to flow from
the ports that have flow enabled to them
you'll see there's a little gap here
where there's
this polymer that separates these rotor
grooves
this was a six port valve it would have
three rotor grooves
uh connecting the set of two two ports
each
so these ports
uh are protected by this uh
polymer material that's uh encased on
the valve
this prevents gases from leaking out of
the valve prevents those gas
atmospheric gases from leaking into the
valve and it prevents gases from
leaking from port to port in the valve
now if you were to get a particle in
here and you were to actuate this valve
and the rotor was to spin the particle
could scar this material
and you could create a small leak
between these ports
and then you would have some issues with
your chromatography because the valve
wouldn't be working properly
and so at that point you have to
disassemble the valve take the rotor out
of the valve
and replace it you can also see here on
the rotor tab there's a ladder
all these rotors that you get we use
mainly valco valves here at
agilent and all the velcro valves have
an id letter on the rotor
that rotor id letter tells you what type
of polymer material
is on the rotor and really this is the
limiting
component to the valve the rest of the
valve is made of stainless steel it's
very durable it's uh it can withstand
really high pressure
but this rotor material cannot it has
very specific properties
that are are going to be specific of
your application and really you need to
be mindful of them
so if you look at this letter e here and
you reference the valco
material you can see here that valcon e
is a polyr ketone pstfe
composite and it has a rating of 400 psi
at about 225 degrees c
so this is what probably 90
or more of the instruments that are
shipped from agilents with valves on
them will have this
uh falcon e rotor and the valves because
it's a pretty general purpose
rating and uh it works with most
applications now
if you have some uh other applications
that are requiring higher pressures
there are some other options and these
are just a few of them there's
there's many more than this but you can
see the valcon p
is a pf ptfe and carbon composite with a
rating of a thousand psi
but it's at the cost of temperature so
if you go to a higher temperature
you would not be able to hold this uh
this pressure rating
and t has a 300 psi rating at 330
uh degrees c so these are things you
have to be mindful of
if you have special applications then
you might need to
uh consider other rotors
other than the falcon e rotor
so you can see here that i've taken uh
kind of what we would normally see in
the valve diagram and i've just overlaid
it on the
on a top down view of a valve to kind of
show you
how these dots and lines relate to the
valve itself so you can see the
connection ports here
and you can see that if we take this you
know in your mind overlay these
connection ports with the dots on the
diagram you can see they directly relate
to
the where the rotor groove is inside of
the valve
and also relative to the ports on the
valve so
the diagram is a direct representation
of the actual valve
so when you're looking at a gc how do
you know where
how the instrument's configured how do
you know where the valves are on the
instrument how do you know
uh what number the valve is configured
so if i want to switch a valve on the
instrument how do i know
by looking at the diagram uh what valve
number relates to the
to the gc on the diagram so if i want to
switch
you know this four port valve here on
this
diagram to the on position how would i
know which valve number
uh on the instrument to select well all
all gcs that ship from agilent that have
valves
on them will come with one of these
diagrams drawn by the factory
and that the valves will be
pre-configured on the instrument
and so you'll know by looking at the
numbers here you can see here
if you look at this diagram it's very
much laid out
like an agilent gc we have our flow
source on the left here
we have the left side of the oven which
is an unheated zone for valves
and then up on top of the instrument we
have the injection ports uh
two different possible injection ports
here these could be any type of uh
injector multi-mode coolant column mmi
ptv and then we have our valve
compartment which usually sits on top of
the instrument
and this happens to be a diagram for a
small valve oven which holds four valves
you can see we have two valve heater
blocks here block one and two and each
one of these blocks holds two valves
and we have our detector zones off on
the right hand side of the instrument
which is generally where the detectors
are mounted unless you're using mass
spec
in which case they'd be mounted on the
left hand side of the instrument
so you have a this four port valve here
if you look
above the valve you see some numbers
here the first number on this diagram is
the valve number and that's the valve
number on the diagram so this is valve
one and it's the valve
on the instrument so when you go to the
instrument if you go to valves on the
keypad
and you select valve one and turn it on
you would be turning
this four port valve on the other
numbers that are on the diagram are some
part numbers that are associated
with the valve itself so this happens to
be an option 904
that you can order uh on a 7890 so a 30
uh 3440 g3440b option 904 would put a
four port valve on a on a 7890 here
we have two 78 90-0
382's which are these inert uh capillary
valve interface bulkheads and an 872
which is a non-inert
uh bulkhead fitting that allows you to
attach a capillary column to this
bulkhead fitting down into the gc oven
so
it brings a bulkhead down from the valve
uh down into the oven where you can make
capillary connections to it
so you can see here these diagrams
become important for
not only you understanding um how your
instruments configured if
if you take on new responsibility and
you inherit an instrument that's
that's already got valves on it you you
can look at these diagrams and
understand pretty quickly how the
instruments configured what's on it and
how it should operate
um it also gives you the power to work
with
agilent to design your own system if you
have some ideas for
oh we want to put valves on this system
to do a certain
uh chromatographic function
then you can work with your your local
agilent team
to get a valve diagram drawn and the
factory will build that diagram to your
specifications so
it's it's it's a great tool for not only
troubleshooting and understanding but
for conveying information back and forth
to agilent
so i'll just pause right here before we
move on because we're kind of going into
another phase here talking about
the functions of the valves from an
application standpoint are there any
questions
um from that uh
from the information i just gave you
there
hey thanks shannon all right let's check
and see i'm just checking the q and a
box
and checking the chat
i don't see any there let's check the
phone lines real quick cecilia
star one for any questions we'll pause
for a moment
and no questions at this time okay back
to you shannon
uh it looks like maybe was there a
question from james boone
uh promise he's a a chat there
i think he's just making some comments
oh okay yeah you're good all right all
right
we're good um
let's see we have let's move on and
let's talk some more about valves here
um feel free to chat in if you have any
comments
um we're gonna start talking about six
port valves you can see here we have a
blank six port valve and one of the
things i want you to think about is
when you are thinking about valves
you don't necessarily have to think
about them in terms of just a blank
valve and
all right if i want a gas sample valve
where am i going to draw the lines in
and
and the loops and that sort of thing uh
to order a gas sample valve from agilent
you don't have to do that
so this is a blank six port valve and
you can see here i have
um eight different six port valves drawn
here
okay this is just a couple of the
different valve configurations that you
could do with six port valves
and you'll see here on these option
numbers
that these are all valves that agilent
will offer and pre-configure for you
so if you order a gc and you want a gas
sample valve
you can just order the g3440 option
701 and that will install a gas sample
valve
already plumbed in a valve box on your
instrument you don't have to think about
that
so you can think about one of the things
i want to
guide you on here is to not necessarily
think about valves as just a blank valve
trying to understand it kind of look at
the bigger picture step back
and look at the shape and the form of
the valve design
and think about those try to learn what
the functions of those particular
designs are
and then you really don't have to think
about trying to figure out exactly
what's going on with the valve so
for instance when i look at this valve
here i don't have to look at this label
here i know this is a gas sample valve
just by looking at it i don't have to
trace the lines and make sure that the
the loop is in the right place and all
of that
so we're going to talk about a couple of
these valves we're going to talk about
these three that i've highlighted here
and walk through their form and function
for you
and we're going to do the same thing for
a few temporary valves
and then we're going to take those
valves and we're going to build up an
application
and i'm going to kind of show you how to
think about that
so here we have a six port valve and
it's a
it happens to be a gas sample valve as
we were just talking about
and we know it's a gas sample valve
because when we look at it we see that
it's got a loop on it
so all gas sample valves are going to
have a loop on and it doesn't matter if
they're
they're six port valves their 10 port
valves or their 16 port valves
so it's a gas sample valve you'll see a
loop on it so you'll know that that
valve is
injecting a sample
the the loop is a fixed volume loop the
the option 701
gas sample valve comes with a 250
or a 0.25 milliliter loop so
a quarter of a mil would be injected
here
and so you can fill this loop by
attaching
either a pressurized gas sample
container
to this inlet here that goes into the
loop or you can attach a
tedlar bag or a syringe with a lure lock
fitting on here
and you can push sample through the loop
and that's how you would load the loop
you could also connect it directly to a
process
there's a few things you have to be
mindful about
when you're when you're loading gas
sample valves
and one is is the um
the sample volume that's inside of the
loop is directly related to the pressure
so that the the loop is a fixed loop
and so being a fixed loop it happens to
be uh
one of the most repeatable forms of
injection
uh depending on one thing and that's if
the pressure is the same
all the time so it's governed by the
ideal gas law so
if you've taken some chemistry you know
pv equals nrt
so if the pressure changes in this loop
if the pressure goes up then the number
of moles in the loop go up
and we inject more sample then as if the
pressure is low and the number of moles
go down we would inject
less sample and so it's important that
we have the bot
the pressure on the loop the same every
time we do an injection all the way from
our standards calibration uh to our
direct sampling
and so how you do that typically is you
would allow sample to flow
through the loop which is going to
require some amount of pressure
it's going to flow out the vent to
atmosphere
and then before you inject you would
stop the flow
on the valve and allow the sample in the
loop to equilibrate to atmospheric
pressure
atmospheric pressure doesn't change
enough uh
over the time frame you know unless
you're in a hurricane or something
that you would see loss of repeatability
and so it's important to adjust it to
atmospheric pressure every time before
you inject and that's how you get good
repeatability out of a gas sample valve
is making sure that pressure is the same
every time
so you can see here i've highlighted and
and will continue to do so throughout
the presentation
um the areas that were
we're concerned with here here we're
filling the the gas sample valve with
a sample we have a carrier gas sweeping
through the valve as well through ports
five and four here out to an inlet or a
column or another valve even
and uh when we're ready to inject we
stop flowing the sample
and then i've drawn this valve in the on
position so i've denoted that it is on
uh so that i know i'm i'm breaking one
of my own rules here to show you
that uh what the valve looks like when
it's in the on position so we're
switching the valve on
the carrier gas is now flowing into the
valve
and instead of bypassing the loop it's
actually flowing through the loop and
pushing sample
out of the loop onto the inlet or the
column and that's how a gas sample valve
works
it's pretty simple valve design
so let's move along now to the six port
column isolation valve
this is a valve that's used when you
need to isolate a column
so here you can see we have a six port
valve we've got a column
here attached to the valve and we have a
restrictor here
when you see this valve design you see
an isolation valve um
and you see emulsive column on it
nine times out of ten you won't even
need to know that what this column is
you're going to know it's almost always
emulsive
when you see uh the six port bypass
valve configuration
with a restrictor on it i honestly i
can't even remember the last time
i saw an application that had this valve
on it that did not have emulsive column
attached to it
and so it's almost always associated
with analyzing light gases
and the reason why is because
the only column that will separate
hydrogen
helium oxygen nitrogen co
methane uh baseline resolution at
ambient temperature
is the uh mulciv column and so it
becomes really important
in in certain types of analyses like
um in some natural gas analysis and some
refinery gas analysis lots of process
and
reactor study gases they're they're
doing a lot of light gas analysis
and so this column
becomes important because it's the only
column that can separate those
components
the downside to it is it has such
resolving
resolution power that any components
co2 and heavier that go on to this
column will
in essence be almost irreversibly
absorbed
so they will retain those components at
such
a high level that you you won't be able
to
uh analyze them or get them off this
column in any any short time
frame uh so it's important that we have
a method
where we can bypass that column uh to
allow those heavier components to flow
past it
so how does it work here we have
a carrier gas you can imagine allowing
some
light gases like helium hydrogen oxygen
nitrogen co
methane to flow on this column
and then before co2 elutes onto the
column
you could switch the valve and then flow
co2 or any heavier uh gas components
around and bypass the valve
now remember now once you switch the
valve to the on position
this column is in a closed circuit so it
has no flow to it so you won't get
any uh linear diffusion
across the valve so you can't hold
components on there for
a long period of time but over
chromatography time
it should be fine and then you can
desorb them later or you could allow
them to flow off
after the the co2 goes past the valve
you should have a gap in your your
chromatography there
it's also important to know when using
bypass valves regardless of what the
column is here and this this becomes
important over a lot of valves
is to consider what the restriction is
across the valve
um and what that is what the effect is
of that restriction
on the crop on the chromatography
upstream and downstream of the valve
that's causing the restriction so you
can see here we have
um carrier guys flowing into port five
and output four and across
this uh this column here column x
and this column has a specific
uh pressure restriction to it
it's it's just a restriction that
happens through the dimensions of the
column and the
packing materials are you know the type
of column you're using even
different columns will have different
dimensions and different packings and
different restrictions associated with
them
so add a pressure uh that's driving the
flow let's say pressure
x across this column
you will get a certain flow rate we'll
just call that flow rate y
it doesn't matter what it is at this
point so at a pressure reacts across
this restriction
we'll get a flow rate y now when we
switch the valve
over here to the bypass position the on
position
if we have that same pressure x and we
have no restriction here
then all of a sudden we're going to see
our flow up
and downstream of this valve increase to
a higher rate
reason why is because we would have no
restriction here so we need to make sure
that we have a restriction here and that
it's
equal to the column restriction and so
i've drawn in a variable restrictor here
it could be a fixed restrictor we do
that often we'll we'll size a restrictor
a piece of open fused silica tubing to
match the
the restriction of this column
and what you do is just turn the uh
the valve to the off position
and apply a pressure a constant pressure
to the column
and measure the flow rate at the outlet
of the detector or
or down or just downstream of the valve
here to see what that flow rate is
and then you turn the valve back on and
you measure the flow rate
again you are going to notice that that
flow rate is different than what you
measured
when the valve was in the opposition so
then you go in
you adjust that restrictor until the
flows match
now when the flows are matching it
doesn't matter what position the valve
is in
the flow is always the same across the
system so that's going to allow you to
to have more predictable and better
chromatography because the last thing
you want is
is the flow rate on your instrument to
be changing without you knowing it
or or have it dependent on the valve
position so that's how six four column
bypass valve works
and those are some of the things that
you need to be mindful of
uh when you're thinking of them and
you're thinking of it
so hopefully the next time you see one
of these valves you'll go oh i know
exactly what that is
it's a six port bypass valve it's i
guarantee you it's all
almost guaranteed it's got emulsive
column on it and you need to make sure
that you're mindful of
the flow balance across the valve those
are the things you need to think about
when you look at valves what kind of
valve is it
what's it doing and what are the the
issues that i need to be mindful about
when using this valve
so moving along now we have a six port
sequence reversal with a pre-column back
flush valve
it's starting to get a little wordy here
but what this valve does
you'll see that it has two columns on it
we have carrier gas coming in the valve
uh into the valve it's pulling through
column one
and it comes back around back into the
valve and then flows through column two
and out to the detector or another valve
or column
and this is one of the one of my
favorite valves i just find this valve
this design fascinating
and and i'll show you why here in a
minute but
anyway this valve allows column one to
switch positions with column two
relative to each other
it operates as a back flush so usually
when you see this valve design
there's typically an aluminum plot or
a gas pro column and
these are columns that are very good at
analyzing
uh light hydrocarbons up through about
c6 to c8
after that they become too retentive and
the analysis time becomes too long
and not everyone really needs to know uh
exactly
you know what's resolved out past those
c6 c8 levels but they might be
interested in
the amount of those hydrocarbons in the
system they just don't need to see how
see the resolution so this valve gives
you the ability
to screen
the heavier hydrocarbons off on a pre
column
and then i'll allow the lighter you know
this would be probably a db1
a short db1 column and i'll allow the
lighter molecules to flow through
we'll just say c1 to c5 or c6
right now to flow through to column two
for for full resolution
if this was an aluminum ply column then
we would have
a good resolution on c4 c5 olefins
and that's probably the best column for
doing c4 c5 olef
analysis but the aluminum plot doesn't
handle the
the heavier hydrocarbons very well so we
would catch those heavier hydrocarbons
up here on this column one
so if you look more closely at the the
flow considerations of the valve
you'll see how carrier gas flows into
the valve and
flows through port five and outpour four
here and we have forward for
flow across column one the flow comes
around
back into port one and out port six
we have forward flow across column two
so in this case our our light
hydrocarbons would flow through this
short db1 because it just
doesn't have enough uh theoretical
plates to hold them up
and the um the heavier hydrocarbons
would hang back onto this column and
slowly start to make their way down this
column
before they get off the column
and on to column two
then oops sorry then we can switch the
valve
to the um on position
and when the valve is in the on position
something interesting happens so if you
go back
and you look at the valve in the off
position
column one is the first column that the
gas is flowing through and column two is
the second column
uh that in in the series when you go to
the
on position now the columns have
swapped positions now column two
is the first column uh it's
column two is upstream of column one so
they've switched positions
we still have forward flow on column two
but column one is now back flushing
so not only have we switched their
positions but we flip flopped column one
around to the opposite direction so now
when you follow the carrier guess
through
you can see that the c1 through c
this hydrocarbons are still resolving on
the aluminum plot
um and they're starting to come off
they're flowing through
ports two and one they're going up
through column one now
in the reverse direction as they start
to make their way on to this column one
all of the c6 plus components have been
made they're stuck on the front of this
column they then get back flushed as a
single peak
off the detector so your first peak top
of this analysis would be a c6 plus peak
and then you would see uh
c1 through c6 start to resolve
off of the aluminum plot they're not
affected much by this short db1 they
flow right through it
up to the detector
you can see here how we can take a valve
and we can use a particular design to
screen off heavier hydrocarbons and then
back flush them
to the to the detector this is commonly
used in
refinery gas applications it's used in
natural gas where they want to get a btu
calculation so they need to know
roughly what the amount of heavy
hydrocarbons are in the system but they
don't necessarily
need to resolve the c6 plus components
they just want to know
the mouth that's there
so any questions so far on those uh six
port valves
you can take a little bit of a break
here and see if there's any questions
popping up
yeah absolutely so again you can ask
questions over the chat box or you can
ask them over the q a box preferably the
q a box and all the panel can see those
questions
and if you have dialed in over the phone
line
you can also press star one and our
operator cecilia
will open your line and just uh so you
know
shannon i had a couple of people comment
saying hello so far
that's okay definitely yeah but hold on
i've got more coming in here
just to give it a say okay so
are the same style of valves used in the
headspace
auto sampler yes so
um there's there's a couple of different
types of valves in the headspace
system there's uh there's some
valves that aren't rotary valves but
the the rotary valves that are used are
are the same as these they're valco
valves
i would have to look at the diagram i
can't remember off the top of my head
exactly how it's configured but the the
headspace system does have a
six port gas sample valve in it it does
okay cecilia let's check those phone
lines
no questions over the phone at this time
okay okay all right shannon back to you
so we'll keep going and hopefully you're
still awake because if you're not asleep
by now
you might be by the end of the temporary
section
here we go with the tempor valve so you
see that uh
we have a blank 10 port valve and one of
the things i always notice is
when you move up to 10 ports things get
significantly more complicated every
time you add two ports to a valve
uh the number of possibilities just
explodes with
with what you can do with it so
you can see here we're going to talk
about focus on
one tempor valve here this is a
this is a 10 port gas sample valve
that's also got
backlished event
functionality to it so in essence it's
doing two things at once
and we'll talk in detail about how this
valve works
now if you want a good homework question
you can look at this valve here this
second valve is
also a 10 port gas sample valve back
flush defense
it actually does exactly the same thing
as this valve but it handles things a
little differently
and flow considerations are taking into
account
more closely with this valve here so if
you look at this valve and you look at
this valve you can
you can ask yourself well which valve
would i want to use and why
i'm talking about this one today because
it's the simplest of the two
for for example purposes
there's also some other valves here
we have a 10 port you'll see now that we
have
inports we have enough room on this
valve to have two gas sample loops
so these loops are when the valve is in
the off position
in parallel so we can load these loops
with two different samples
this becomes a really good valve if you
have an analysis where you want to load
sample
and you want to load an internal
standard at the same time
you can see here that we can fill this
with the second loop here with the
sample
and the sample will go out to its own
vent and you can
uh fill this first loop here with
internal standard
when you inject the valve both valves
get swept by the same carrier gas
and both get and both loops get injected
the same
channel so you inject both samples
together so you're injecting two
different samples to the same inlet
this valve does something very similar
only it's taking
the same lan sample and two loops
and injecting them on
two different channels or two different
inlets this is a valve we use very often
at agilent
where if you have a case where you're
designing an instrument
and you need two six port gas sample
valves
to inject the same sample onto
two different inlets or
to two different valves or to two
different columns however your system is
designed
this is a valve that you can consolidate
those two six poor gas sample valves
into
into just one 10 port dual loop gas
sample valve
so in this case we have one sample
coming into the valve
and if you follow the flow path here it
fills both
loops and then if you look here when the
sample is injected
each one of these loops still gets
injected to these two different columns
or to these
or to two different inlets separately
so this one the loops are in series when
the valve is off
and this one the loops are in parallel
when the valves are off
this is another 10 port valve design
that
i've had a lot of interest in over the
years um
a lot of times customers customers will
come to me and they say
oh i have a gc where i'm having to swap
columns out a lot
i have an inlet detector i've just got a
single column
that i'm doing analysis on and every now
and then uh someone in another group who
is also using this gc
wants to come in and install a second
column and do an analysis and then leave
but we don't want to have to unplug the
columns every time
you can use this temport
column selection design to handle that
for you
so if you look at this design it
requires
two flow sources so you'd have to have
an aux controller you'd have your inlet
hooked up to
one of the columns so let's say our
inlet is hooked up to this
this inlet here on the valve if you
follow it through
it flows through this column and then
out to a detector
if you look at what the other aux flow
is doing it
is coming in this other inlet here
and it's back flushing this column out
then so in a column selection mode
you could select between two different
columns
on the same inlet and detector without
having to
remove those columns from the instrument
just by turning this valve on and off
the nice thing i like about it is is
when it's in one position or the other
one column is selected the other column
is being back flushed and cleaned up
so the other column is always ready to
be used and conditioned
uh when it's time to put it in you don't
have to wait on the time to install
or wait on the the column to be baked
out and cleaned up it's always in the
oven it's always being heat cycled
you do have to be mindful of
the different temperature limitations of
the columns
if you've got a column where you're
running a method very hot and you have
another column
in the same oven that that can't that
doesn't have a high enough max
temperature rating to handle that
temperature
then you could potentially uh destroy a
column
uh inadvertently and to make sure that
the columns are temperature compatible
with both methods that you'll be running
so that's a design we see a lot so let's
move forward and talk about this
this is the uh import gas sample valve
with
pre-column backflushed event it can be
ordered as a g3440b option 801
we'll stall it on the instrument for you
it'll come plumbed up just like this
on your instrument and it's a way to
uh do a couple of things
you're you're starting to see a common
theme here with
rotary valves oh look it's got a gas
sample loop on it so we know it's a gas
sample valve
oh look it's got an another aux flow
zone
and we can tell just by glancing here
that this this column
is being uh back flush to vent
so we know immediately by looking at
this
design that this is going to be some
pre-screening column that
we're using in the application if we're
screening components
we're probably screening the heavier
molecules and so
we're allowing some lighter components
to flow through this
this column two to a detector
um or to another valve and so we see
that
just by looking at these valves you can
immediately recognize the function of
them and you really don't have to pay
that much attention to um
[Music]
you know all the little details of
trying to figure out what the valve is
doing every time just by glancing at
these different functional pieces that
are hanging off the valve
you can immediately recognize what the
valve is what it's doing
and you can probably make a really good
educated guess about what the columns
are
nine times out of ten this valve design
is used with
permanent gas type applications and
it always has a pre-screening column
here that's some sort of haysep
forest polymer column it could be a q or
a sub a
or a sub t of some sort
um or some other column that's that's
that would work well for screening
the molecules of interest and
this column 2 is
either another variant of that column if
we're allowing
lighter uh we're wanting to get some
separation between some
mid-range or or light to mid-range
hydrocarbons or this could be emulsive
um if you look at this valve and you see
that emulsive
is on this column two position here
you will know what the analysis is it's
always
either hydrogen or helium analysis
you could also be looking at oxygen or
nitrogen
but you know that emulsive column you
can't allow co2
or anything heavier uh to go on that
column
so you would know that you would be back
flushing them
there's no bypass on it the only other
option is
is is to bypass those lighter components
but you know if you see a molsiv here
you're probably doing a hydrogen
analysis nine times out of ten you could
be doing an oxygen or nitrogen analysis
but you know that all the heavier
components including co2 are being back
flushed because we can't allow them to
go on that mulciv
so now you know just by looking at this
what it's doing you don't you don't
really need to think about much more
you may ask yourself though how did
someone uh
come to uh the 10-4
design and i was thinking about this one
day and i
i think what happened is if somebody had
a
you know two six ports and you can see
here we have a six port gas sample valve
and you have a six port back flush to
vent valve
and they notice that there's some
commonality between these two valves and
the in the gas inlet ports they have
gas flowing in to port two here and
outport one
then it flows over to this other six
port valve flows into
port 2 prime i've labeled it in one
prime and out to the detector so
these ports are really doing the same
thing and as long as the valve
is in the same these two valves are in
the same state at all times
then we could combine them here we have
two six port valves and we have 12
ports if we eliminate the common port
two of the common ports then we go down
to ten ports
and if we keep the design the same you
can see here i have gas
flowing in port two and out port one
and over to the column or the detector
and in essence that's what i'm doing
here
gasoline in port 2 and outport 1 to a
column and a detector
we maintain the gas sample
functionality of the 10 port valve you
can see 3 4
5 and 6 are the same as 3 4 5 and six on
the ten port valve here
so we've maintained that functionality
and we've
stolen the back flush vent functionality
from this six port valve
and placed it in the same position seven
eight nine and ten
on this temporary valve so you can see
here we've maintained
all of the functionality as long as all
we need is
the same on off state of these two
valves
into one and you just saved yourself a
lot of money by only buying one valve
one actuator
and uh one heated zone on the gc
so um it's important to think about
these things
uh from a monetary standpoint as well as
maintenance standpoint over time and
also
ease of application setup
so let's talk a little bit more about
how the
the back pre-column back flush to dent
works you can see in the off position we
got two things going on where
we could be loading sample um
through the gas sample loop and we're
back flushing
column one so if there are any
hydrocarbons on column one
or any other components for that matter
when the valve is in the opposition they
will always be backflush to vent
so when we're ready to do our next
analysis
our column one column which is our
cleanup column so to speak to
to scrub the heavier uh
molecules will be ready for its
its function its chromatography function
when the valve's on
pcm1 is providing flow
to column two and and to the detector
but when the valve is switched on now
the sample
is bypassing the loop
the flow module is providing flow to the
valve and sweeping the sample from the
loop
and all of our analytes are going on to
column one
and a four direction flowing through
column one into the valve
and into column two
where more separations are happening
once we've got
the analytes of interest onto column two
like i said before usually light gases
we're going to switch this valve back to
the opposition
and go back into sample load and column
one cleanup mode
or we're back flushing the vent here and
analytes are flowing off
further resolving off through the
chromatography system here to the
detector
so that's how pre-column back flushed
event valve works
and now with that knowledge you can look
at a diagram
and go oh i i
can start to see in my mind now
what's going on with this
more complex design you look at this
design and you look at each one of these
valves and you immediately start to
recognize what they're doing based on
the information i just gave you
and you'll see these common themes
throughout all valve chromatography
and so even though this looks
complicated you'll notice that oh
there's really only four valves in use
in this system
we know immediately just by looking at
it that two of them are gas sample
valves
we know this is a six port and it's only
got a loop on it so it's a six port gas
sample valve it's just being used to
inject sample that's all it's doing
and we have this we have two of these
temporary gas sample valves which we
already talked about this is the one we
just discussed the pre-column backlished
event
and oh this is a a six port
bypass valve and we know that these
valves always
almost always have an aluminum or
emulsive column on them so this is
this is being used to resolve permanent
gases
and this valve here
is usually got an aluminum plot and a
dv1 on it
and it's being used to do a c6 plus or
c8 plus back flush
so you know about all these valves
already so you know
exactly what the system's doing
now one of the other uh things i
typically look at is how the sample
loops are
are configured so if we just kind of
focus in on
one of the sample loop one the gc sample
loops here
you can see that immediately we have
three gas sample valves in this
application
and we have all of the sample loops are
connected
so if you follow the sample flow through
the valves
you see that each loop is being filled
by the same sample
so you can see here that that the same
sample is flowing through
all of the valves there all the loops
are connected in series so
we know we're only analyzing one sample
here
it's just that up on injection we're
breaking those
those analyses out into three parts to
accomplish
some chromatography that we couldn't do
on a single column
so as i think i mentioned before when
you
when you read diagrams try to focus on
one thing when you're if the diagram's
really complicated
and i know it's when you see the diagram
and it's it's got all the lines on the
and the valves on the page it's easy to
look at the middle of the diagram and
kind of just get lost in it
what you need to do is start pick pick a
flow source
and follow that flow source through the
system and that'll help you isolate
what's going on this is how the gases
flow
through the instrument they flow from
left to right
when you're looking at the the actual
instrument and they flow from left to
right on the diagram as well
they flow from the flow source it's
providing the pressure to drive the flow
through the system to the detector so if
you follow this
channel one here you can see that it
flows through
this valve this gas sample this temporal
gas sample valve
flows through the column and off to a
tcd detector
this so happens that this is a
small civ column connected to this g to
this valve here
this is a haysep column it's it's
screening everything heavier than
uh oxygen and nitrogen and back flushing
at the vent
and we're analyzing a hydrogen
in a refinery gas on this column
and we're using an argon carrier
but by just by looking at this valve
configuration like i told you before
it's just a 10 port gas sample
back flush to vent valve if you see that
it's got emulsive on it
and there's no downstream valves or
other columns
you know that it's doing a hydrogen and
helium analysis
especially if you see argon carrier or
nitrogen carrier gas
and it's going to this tcd and
sure enough there's a small chromatogram
we can see
one single hydrogen peak in this
analysis
let's move on to the second channel
and if you follow the the flow diagram
from left to right start with the flow
source
flow up through the valve and we can see
that this
gas sample 10 port gas sample back flush
to vent valve
also has haysteps on it when samples
injected goes through both hay steps
there's not a mole sieve here but it
flows through
to a six port bypass valve that we
talked about this six port bypass valve
does have a molsiv on it
we're using helium carrier gas on this
channel
and we're using this moulsiv
to resolve oxygen nitrogen co
and methane and we're allowing
co2 and c one to see
two hydrocarbons to bypass
this uh emulsive flow around to the tcd
and um then we're analyzing
the the lighter gases and you can see a
small chromatogram i'll show a bigger
one here in a minute
um and so this is also
part of the permanent gas analysis
channel of this refinery gas system
but just by looking at these common
valve
combinations and recognizing what each
channel is doing you can immediately
start to piece together what the
application is and it
and then it's not as intimidating as
trying to
trying to figure thing out figure the
system out in such a detailed manner
so if we go over to uh the third channel
we can
flow through this this system we see we
go through the six port gas sample valve
that's being injected into a split inlet
which allows us to
split the sample control the the amount
of sample going on to the
the gc column and we're flowing into
a six port series reversal valve and i
told you before that
these valves are almost always used in
c6 plus back flush considerations with
aluminum plot columns and that's exactly
what this is
uh we're doing a c1 to c6 analysis with
a c6 plus backslash to an fid we're just
analyzing hydrocarbons
so if you look here
and you look at this analysis that's
actually what you see
the first peak is on the fid channel a
c6 plus peak then we get our c4 c5
uh olefin resolution off of
of that channel off the aluminum plot
but this you know now that how this
works the c6 plus got hung up on that
first db1
column and that sequence reversal valve
we then flipped their positions and
and flipped the the db1 so that it was
flowing backwards we backflips to c6
plus off first
and then all the other components come
through it off the alumina plot
to the f to the fid fully resolved
you look at the 10 port gas sample valve
back flush
vent in series with a 6
port bypass valve on this tcd
channel you see that your first peak
is co2
now you might wonder well co2 is the
largest molecule
in this group of molecules why on earth
is it coming off first
because we allowed these lighter
oxygen nitrogen methane co to flow off
of those first two columns on that pin
port valve
onto the mole sieve where we trapped
them
in on the bypass valve when we turned it
on
we allowed co2 to flow around
these components elute first then we
turn the valve back to the off position
and eluded
oxygen nitrogen methane and co and that
allowed us to
prevent co2 from going on to
the mulciv and we back flushed any
components heavier than that
so if you were to look at this diagram
or if you were to look at these
chromatograms
and you were to go oh co2 came off first
and then i have a permanent gas you
don't even have to think about it you
know that's a 10 port gas sample
back flushed event in series with a six
port bypass valve
so when you see it on the diagram you
know what you know that the chromatogram
is going to look like this
and vice versa so think about it in
terms of
of function giving a certain
chromatographic
result and have a picture in your mind
what the valve design is that
accomplishes that
then when you look at the diagram you
don't have to think as hard about it
because you know what it's doing
so here we have a 10 port gas sample
valve
where the mould sieve is on the 10 port
valve we're back flushing everything
heavier than helium and hydrogen
and we're just doing a hydrogen analysis
so hopefully
i was able to give you some tools
that you can use in the future for
better understanding valves
i'll be happy to hang on here and answer
any questions that you have
if you have any and feel free to send me
an email as well
if if you want to
all right thank you shannon for your
very informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please please do so now
and just click the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and let's just see if you have any
questions
okay um it looks like
we are coming close to an end today um
there's no questions at this moment but
if you would like to
submit a question um the all the
questions will be addressed by your
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration
um this and let me just double check
there's no questions
sounds great thank you so much for your
participation today and thank you again
shannon
for your wonderful presentation and this
webcast can be viewed on demand through
november
2021 and until next time
thank you and have a great day